Hello and
welcome everyone to the Active
Inference Lab.
Today is January 10th, 2022,
and we're here in active
cash stream number 14
with a whole host of awesome guests.
We're going to be discussing
osteopathy and mental health,
and we're going to have the authors
say hello and introduce themselves.
Then Lucas will give a presentation,
and during the presentation
please feel free to add your comments
and questions in the live chat,
and then we'll have a bunch of time
after the presentation
to ask those questions to the authors.
Here. Any authors remarks?
So really excited to hear from you all
and learn from your perspective.
Let's hear the introductions
from the authors and then go to Lucas.
So please Robert,
and then we'll kick it off from there.
Thank you.
Robert Shaw.
I'm based in Sweden
and a psychotherapist.
My research interest
is particularly within embodiment,
and that was what my Ph.D.
was on embodiment
within the therapeutic relationship
Hi, everyone.
I'm Francesco, totally from Italy.
I'm a neuroscientist and osteopath
mainly
interested in discovering the
how the brain works in relation
to touch a relation
to the effect of touch
based on the different type of stimuli
that the body received
I am sure it just means I'm an octopus.
Currently based in Malta and Italy.
I'm also cognitive scientist
and my main interest is on predictive
processing, activating friends,
touch and chronic pain
in general.
Yeah.
Hi, my name is Lucas.
I think I'm the last of the authors,
so I'm an osteopath as well,
based in Hamburg in Germany,
and I'm currently working part time
at the Osteopathic Research Institute,
and I'm working on education, education
and research, and I'm also part time
studying psychology and in science
that's meant to have at King's
College in London.
And I think I. Can.
Kick off the presentation now.
That's OK with you on
perfect.
Thanks so
yeah, we have the opportunity.
Thanks again for the Active Endurance Lab
for the invitation.
It's it's a pleasure to be here.
We have the opportunity
to present a paper that you have recently
published on Frontiers in Psychology
in the section of Psychology
Research Topic, Journal, Content
Activism and Active Opinions
in the Therapeutic Alliance,
and the papers entitled Osteopathy
A Mental Health and Body Productive
and Introspective Framework
and without further ado, I think
let's let's dove right into it.
A little introduction on on
why these things might be interesting
we have a globally
a very high prevalence and a burden,
but also comorbidity
between most skeletal
and mental health disorders.
So to put this in perspective,
about 1 billion prevalent cases of mental
disorders have been reported in 2017
about 1.3 billion
prevalence cases have been reported.
Most of it is autism and 17.
So together these two broad spectrum
disorders are very prevalent
but also burdensome.
So together
those health conditions contribute
to what
are the main contributors
to work by disability.
But system of demented is disorders
also highly co-morbid
which means for example,
a anxiety depression not frequently
to our core common in depression,
most pain conditions and vice versa.
So for example depressive
symptoms are quite prevalent
and pain sufferers and pain symptoms
are also quite prevalent
in individuals with depression
so these
this data kind of outlines
a need to integrate physical and mental
health care services in our opinion,
but also in the opinion of
many research papers in the literature.
So especially multidisciplinary
collaborations between most skeletal
and psychology of health care
specialists have been called for.
But on the other hand
there have also been some disease
classifications that have been proposed
to combine physical and mental health
and proposed classifications
that are made actually somatic,
purely mental.
So we believe that there is this need
to integrate these kind of approaches,
and we like to propose osteopathy
to be to be one of these approaches
and osteopathy,
for those who don't notice, is generally
used primarily to treat most facility
disorders like back pain.
But it is also
has recently been proposed to benefit
psychosocial factors in particular,
and in patient populations
with persistent pain.
And there have also
there was also some research
that has been conducted from Hillary,
ABN and colleagues
showing some positive outcomes
of combined treatment
as well as the combined osteopathy
and combined psychological
informed strategies
showing positive results.
So now a few attempts to investigate
the effectiveness of osteopathy
in the field of mental health.
And there are only a few approaches
being developed
to treat
how to engage with mental health.
So based on this background, we propose
we try to propose
a framework on how to move forward
and how to research the status of such
supposed to be in this field.
And we do so by drawing together
from the research
fields and body position,
predictive coding,
but also interception and sympathy.
And we like to propose in the end
our framework,
which is an embodied predictive
and intrusive performance.
And if you look on the right hand side,
see the one,
this is kind of our background
I put together a simplified body position
kind of highlights the role of the body
in population and in mental health.
And these process processes
are likely underpinned
by predictive coding processes.
So for them, our access point,
we discuss intercepts
as an access point, point of access point
to affect these processes.
And we argue that osteopathy might be
an approach to to realize this. And
so let's have a look at the background.
We start with the first research field,
which is embodied tradition
and generally embodied and body medicine,
interdisciplinary field of research
which spans disciplines
including philosophy, but also
psychology, psychiatry and neuroscience.
And in general, these theories
of embodiment argue that cognition
and emotion are both dependent
on embedded body simulations.
So they argue that body and mind
are inseparable in producing cognition
and that the non neural body might both
constrain and enable cognition,
but not until they are stronger
and which are versions of embodiment.
Some idea that the body might contributes
to cognitive processes,
while other versions argue
that it might constitutes
cognitive processes
so to get a little bit
more detail
involved theories of embodiment
of that condition of emotional based upon
reinstatement of perception.
So this is relating
to both external extra receptors
and entering
into receptive sensory states,
but also to actually which relates
to proprioceptive motor states.
And these perceptions produce embodied
sensory model simulations
which previous experiences in one's self.
So this is
kind of the explanation of embodiment.
And this perspective is quite interesting
because it might revise our brain
centered view of cognition
by acknowledging that these processes
are not simply limited to neural events
in the brain, but also concepts across
the brain, body and blood divisions
and should be also studied accordingly.
And there are different kinds
of commitment to the embodied theories
and an active isn't this interesting
aspect, linked concept that I want you
to go into a little bit further
and connected in propose that cognition
emerges from the dynamic interaction
of brain, body and also environment.
So most of you
might have heard
about the faulty cognition,
which is that cognition is all together
embodied, embedded
connected, extended,
but also psychological.
And we are it is argued
that cognition is an important
but it's an extended
and ecological process
of sense
making through a body in an environment.
So this is an evaluative
evaluate is interaction of an organism
and its environment.
So in each of these four
or five used to mean that body cognition
is an average tool and also constrained
by the non-euro body.
Embedded means
that cognition depends
on the environment, the context
as the organism is situated
within the environment
and connected means that provision
for action depends on the interaction
of the embodied organisms
with the environment.
And extended means that cognition extends
beyond the brain and body
into the environment.
The most notable example
might be your smartphone.
And lastly,
ecological means that cognition
depends on the environmental affordances
for for action.
And all together this might constitute
an activism with a five perspective.
So combining these perspectives
of embodied and connective
and activism, both mental
and physical health conditions,
for example, pain and depression
are associated with altered interaction
with an eye
toward interaction of the organism with
and with with the environment
through its embodiment.
So it's the three part
engagement, brain, body and environment.
So to
sum this up, embodiment and activism
emphasize the interaction of brain, body
and environment in understanding
the mind and permission and
to understand the processes of the brain.
In a little bit more detail, we have to
turn to another bit of research,
which is the next part of the deadline
because this predictive, Tony,
and I believe that predictive coding,
this is a topic
most of the listeners
are more familiar with than us.
But I try to summarize them anyway.
So predictive
processing is a theoretical framework
with growing influence and the field
of cognitive science, and it is closely
related but also distant, distinct
from the free energy principle.
I usually bring hypotheses into action
in theory, and so I would summarize all
of them closely.
So the
free energy principle proposes
that living systems
resist the tendency to disorder,
or in other words,
remain in thermodynamic non
equilibrium state and states,
and they do so by restricting themselves
to a limited number of states
through the minimization of production.
And in this instance,
free energy is defined as the difference
between the systems
predicted and actual states,
and this can be minimized using
both perception and action in perception.
It is minimized
by updating the prediction that is
made from the generated model
based on the sensation
and action in turn
changing this information
to actually to match with the prediction.
So it's like a simple thing prophecy
and the eye usually brain hypothesis
proposes that brains making predictions
about the causes of extra
receptive and receptive, but also
proprioceptive sensations using both
the sensory input but also prior beliefs
based on the generated model
and in
general the confidence of precision.
One has
in the belief by the player
and the sensory input or the likelihood
will determine how much the perception
would then
and shift towards the expectation.
So in general,
the gap between play on likelihood
this kind of prediction, error,
free energy,
and while the system is minimizing
prediction, error,
free energy or surprise or entropy,
that is also maximizing
the evidence
for its own model of the world.
And this is the by using brain hypothesis
this is related to behavior.
So predictive coding is putting this
into a neural perspective and proposing
sets down descending top down predictions
that are conveyed.
Biological levels don't look like levels
where they are compared to us
and what our sensory information
so from this
perspective information
only goes up the cortical hierarchy.
And if a mismatch between the predicted
natural information occurs
which is a prediction error
and otherwise top down predictions
constantly explain away
what sensory information. Is.
So then there is active inference
which proposes
that the brain actively modifies
its input to confirm prior expectations
and this is an active and also selective
sampling sensory information
in the world who actually so prediction
errors can be minimized.
Talked about it a little bit
through perceptual insurance and active
inference.
Perceptive inference,
meaning revising the generated model
based on the prediction
was an active influence
acting on the words to generate a state
that is predicted by the general judgment
and to bring all of this together
with the physical and mental health
condition and to understand the physical
and mental health conditions,
it might be an
ultimate weighting of prior beliefs
and sensory information
which gives rise to physical
or mental health conditions.
So, for example, physical health
conditions,
prior beliefs are likely overweighted
relative to sensory information,
which means a far too much prediction
precision,
which then predicts symptoms
consequently experienced
and this might also lead to heightened
prediction of pain
even towards the sensations
so that harmless sensations
might be perceived as painful
and on the other hand,
mental health conditions,
both prior
beliefs might be overly precise
in comparison to sensory information
or vice versa.
So the first one is depression
and the second one in psychosis.
And yes,
so one point that was quite
interesting
is that chronic pain of depression,
which we are quite interested
in, are particularly linked to thoughts
and chances of interception
that some in literature involve this.
So this is our next research topic
that we want you to
combine with the other ones
so what is interception
I have defined interception
as the process
by which the nervous system senses,
interprets and integrates segments
originating from within the body.
So it's all information
from within our body.
And this provides
some kind of embodied sensory experience
which is absolutely necessary
for the adaptive interaction
with the environment.
So an interesting aspect
is that the active inference
model was also applied to intercept,
which is termed intercepted endurance,
and it proposes
that intercept experiences result
from inferences about the hidden costs
of this sensory information.
So to put this into the neuro
perspective,
our top down intercept of predictions
compared with bottom up
intercept intercept information
most likely on the insula
and the mismatch between
those then results and prediction error,
which is minimized
depending on the the precision
by either perceptual inference
are active inference.
So perceptual experience means revising
the top down deceptive predictions
and active appearance means
then modifying the bottom up intercept
of information to convey the prediction.
And interestingly, Andy has proposed that
an emotion can also be viewed
as intercepted in sequence
because intercept of predictive
errors are used
to an emotional space.
So to connect this to physical
and mental health conditions and deficits
and intercept of processing
for example,
the lower intercept of accuracy
might be associated
with both physical and mental health
conditions
led to payment and commodity oppression.
However, there is
it is not clear how
that every disorder in every individual
might behave the same in this way.
I think the difference is so
so some disorder, some individuals
would likely benefit from reducing overly
precise intercepted predictions,
for example, growing beliefs about real
but indeed harmless sensations,
while other patients might might reduce
overly precise perceptive information,
which is, for example,
illusory sensations that are maintained
that maintain warring beliefs
so that both possibilities.
So let's talk about our approach on
how to influence up to its information.
And this is osteopathy,
the osteopath, the office on this paper.
So a few words about osteopathy.
Osteopathy, combines
hands on manual approaches with hands off
patient management approaches.
So we use touch and manipulation
as hands on, which is informed
by synthetic models of care.
So our clinical reasoning
and hands of patient manage approaches
involve patient education, psychological
support, lifestyle advice, but also
self-management management solutions.
And these are informed,
of course, by most geographic principles.
But notably,
both might utilize a top down
and bottom up dynamics
between personal tissues and the brain.
Yes. So in
general, osteopathy is applied
to treat a range of clinical conditions,
but an emphasis is given on chronic pain
conditions
in particular,
most particularly dissatisfied segment
and philosophically,
Osteopathy has emphasized
the unity and interaction of body,
mind and soul for quite some time.
And it has also been proposed
that it might
benefit psychological outcomes,
especially in chronic pain patients.
But this needs some further research and
Francesco and colleagues also proposed
that osteopathic treatment
might influence intercepted processing.
And in the concept paper
they published in I think 2060
and went on to conduct
some primary research showing
that osteopathy indeed increases
contraceptive accuracy.
But also decreases the bench
response of brain correlates
of interception
in patients with chronic back pain.
So they do so probably
by the stimulation, often
see tactile fibers
which communicate intercepted
and affective dimensions of touch.
So this could be relevant to both
physical and mental health conditions
that involve intercept of deficits,
which are, for example,
chronic pain and also depression
so this is all background.
And I think that really up
to the framework we like to present
and the framework
which all of these fields of research
and it is an embodied, introspective
but also predictive framework.
And the basic basis
is that both physical and mental
health symptoms
may result from outright precision
weighting between intercepts, predictions
and intercept input.
So we argued that on the literature,
I guess that I've had too much precision,
which is an
overly precise prediction
on automated precision.
It's a follow up to the likelihood
which is an imprecise prediction.
So arguably from any depression
mainly linked to the operating of trials.
So these beliefs likely predict
painful and depressive states,
even if the actual intercepted
information is harmless.
And they do so due to past experiences,
and they likely make these states
come true through active experiences.
So the expected symptoms
might be generated through action
to confirm the prediction
and in order to update
these prior beliefs
and reduce the influence of pain
and depressive states,
it is likely that surprising intercept
input needs to be provided
to increase, first of all, the rate
of the likelihood, but also to generate
prediction errors that can revise
the belief system with the predictions
and thus steps likely to foster
perception influence.
So actual information
is used in perceptual insurance
to propagate the prediction and also
the perception of these symptoms.
And we have to look at 52 in a moment.
So this
a paper by far from 2015
which which has argued
that contemplative practices
may alter intercept of processing,
shifting regulatory habits
from active to positive influence.
And we believe that it osteopathy
does the same so
if we have to look at our main
we propose that
we see a patient in red
lying on the treatment table.
Imagine this patient has
chronic pain with comorbid depression
and he's lying there and the osteopath
provides some touch based interventions
that to the symptomatic area in this
this image of the upturn
and we argue that
the belief or the plight of the patient
is likely to predict
physical and mental states
that are associated with pain depression
because to be the likely
because of uncertain information
and this is the overweighting
of the problem
but if we provide some treatment
interventions to the patients,
the sensory input is not linked
to these physical and mental states,
which is surprising
but osteopathic treatment
often does not involve
pain, but is quite pleasant
if you if you touch a patient.
So this is a surprising mismatch of calls
to the patients, to the patient,
because the expected
and reaction information do not match
and thus generate
an intercept prediction.
Right.
So these prediction errors need
to be minimized and it can be minimized
using actuarial perception insurance
and in chronic pain.
We argue that high precision is a product
to the belief to the prior, and low
precision is flooded with the sensory
information and the likelihood.
So the first process that needs to engage
is active appearance,
which likely produces the symptoms
that are resembling the predicted states
so likely the autonomic nervous system
is engaged to produce sensations that
resemble the expected
painful and depressive
so however, we are in the health care
context and osteopathic treatments,
so the patient might also be the client
that declined to
to think that this is to help
promote intervention.
So this is not
not and this is contradicted
with the map with the prediction.
So this activity might not
be sufficiently
to to reduce and explain
the intercept of prediction errors.
So consequently, we added that perceptual
appearances processes might be engaged
to update the belief and employer
based on the likelihood.
So the sensory information
provided by the osteopath
might objectively by the patient
and thereby
revising the generative model,
holding the belief
and issuing the prediction.
So we agree that these are the processes
that underpin osteopathic treatment
in these kinds of patients,
and especially when an emotional
reaction and treatment
develops. So
yeah, and in essence,
we argued that belief
and the prediction
of physical and mental states
that are associated
with pain of depression are updated
through these interventions.
So the the persistent and noisy
deceptive predictions errors
which maintain these symptoms through
active interference might be replaced
with surprising imprecise interceptor
patient errors to alleviate the symptoms.
Septuagint.
So this is in a nutshell, our framework
and we also of course
need to discuss this framework
and have looked at some implications
also of limitations.
So in general, I like to emphasize
that this theoretical framework
is a theoretical framework and therefore
requires experimental scrutiny
for verification of quantification
so future research
particularly needs to explore
osteopathic treatment, immediate
physical and mental symptoms.
And this patient population also,
if it actually
increases intercept accuracy
in this population and likely also
decreases allostatic load and modulates
autonomic nervous system activity.
So there are two measurement tools
we can use for that,
and other limitations
include the disregard of complexity.
Both of we have conditions
but also of the therapeutic approaches.
So osteopathy and dementia and depression
and and chronic pain
are all very complex conditions
and we have simplified them extremely.
So we overlooked environmental
factors and we didn't
go into
explaining the patient
therapist relationship in detail as well.
But this framework
should be understood in this context.
So it should be understood
in the person centered context
and the future studies might
also have a look
at why monolithic
treatment of peripheral tissues
sometimes leads to autonomic
and emotional responses.
And I think this is the basically
why I was so interested in this research
and these theories, because in practice
I frequently engage patients
which responded quite emotional
to touch and felt better after.
So I wanted to to understand
how this might happen.
So based on our hypothesis,
you can see in figure three
that the therapeutic input
that is provided during treatment
may contradict the predicted state
of pain and depression and produce
an interesting prediction error
which is used to in emotional states
and minimalize minimize
risk perception insurance.
And what you can see
is that the initial active inference
is quite correct and chart
and we have seen or I've seen
and my colleagues as well from experience
that often these patients
display emotional responses to treatment.
They firstly experience
some sympathetic activity
like sweating and muscle tightness
combined with emotional distress
for example, starting to cry.
But these initial reactions frequently
are replaced with very
positive, sympathetic activity.
So the breathing goes down
and the patient starts
to relax and emotional calmness
starts to set in.
And I believe this is quite
well explainable with the framework
that we have provided to you
because an active inference
might be the first way to engage
in minimizing these prediction errors
and perceptive influence
might be the second more sustainable way
of minimizing these predictions. So
lastly, you can see
another idea
which might come from this framework,
and this is the grant
for multidisciplinary collaborations
in the treatment of mental and physical
disorders.
So we propose a kind of
integrative intercept of exposure therapy
in which both
physical but also mental health care
specialists can come together and
work in a multidisciplinary
but also person centered care approach.
And the idea is that you can see
on the left hand side here is that
mindfulness
practice is likely work top down
in the patient to attend to the sensation
that she is experiencing,
but also affecting the sensory
information like osteopathic work
and bottom up,
also affecting the sensory information by
producing a scent sensation itself.
And psychotherapy
is likely to top down to help identify
and also reflect on the sensation
and like it works and
works on the client at least
directly,
not through the sensory information.
So these are a few few future
research ideas
and now we can complete
this presentation
and to put on all together
this hypothesis and the reality to
propose the embodied predictive
and intrusive framework.
And it does so to reason and research.
The effect of osteopathic treatment
has putatively
come out of psychological factors
in patients
with persistent and physical conditions.
And one of the basic ideas
is that persistent
physical and mental conditions
like chronic pain and depression
may be underlined
by first overly precise
intercept of predictions,
meaning that a symptom controlled
inflammation is expected
and second, imprecise intercept
is prediction errors, meaning that
symptom
incomplete information is not sensed.
So osteopathic treatment may provide
uncertain and surprising intercept
of information to the bodily area
that is associated with a physical
and also comorbid mental symptoms
resulting in intercepted
prediction errors that first engage
a disappearance processes
which lead to initial autonomic activity
resembling the predicted symptoms
and this is
because it is the most likely cause
of uncertain
intercept information due to the past
experiences of the patient
and afterwards
due to the contextual factors,
the information likely engages
perceptual inference processes
that then appear to be maladaptive
and just such predictions based on
the actual intercept of information
and osteopathy, might also actually
improve the ability to attention
to actual intercept of information
so in a nutshell, persistent and noisy
intercept of predict knows
that maintain the symptoms
are likely replaced with surprising,
precise and perceptive predictions
that arguably alleviate the symptoms.
And in this way treatment might reduce
the beliefs about and also the prediction
of physical states that are associated
with chronic depression.
And we are currently also
at the Osteopathic Research
Institute conducting research
into these approaches.
So Tulsi has also joined us
today, has developed
an approach on psychosomatic osteopathy
and we're currently having a look
on how these techniques might influence
stress levels in healthy participants,
but also with patients
with chronic tension type
headaches or chronic muscles.
Can I take this one?
So maybe there's some things
to follow on in the future.
So that's it.
Thank you very much for your attention.
I'm really looking forward
to the discussion and to engaging
Robert, George and Francesco
and you,
I mean, references,
and I think that's one of them shortly.
And if someone's interested
I think they can get the presentation.
So I've done it yes.
But no, that's it.
Thanks, Lucas.
That was an awesome presentation.
Really a lot to think and talk about.
So perhaps we'll first just open it
up to any of the authors and colleagues
here.
Please just jump in wherever you'd like.
I think it'd be awesome to hear about
just your overview or what
brought you to this area of research,
as well as anything that you picked up on
from this last presentation.
I think maybe I can say a few words
because I forgot something
in the beginning, so it all started
with with George and Francesco
inviting Robert and me
to join our research group that tries to
to reconceptualize osteopathic care
and the active adherence framework.
So we have a group of osteopath
from Europe working
with the Edge of Influence Framework,
and now also other papers coming in.
A special topic, which is also
has been edited
by edited by George and Francesco.
So there are other ideas
coming forward in the near future.
I think 11 thing that's
I guess brought us into this area
is a sort of a way
of looking into how we can best
help our patients, and particularly those
with present with complexity
including chronic pain, but not just by,
you know, the broad sort of area,
persistent physical symptoms,
you know, those that tend to sort of
go around, see different practitioners,
look for a solution to that problem,
try to know what's going on and,
you know, we tend to sort of see them in
practice and struggle at times.
If we use
a very reductionist approach
to practice,
which is do a manual intervention
and hope for the best, you know,
that's that's far from, you know,
from what is best practice
these days, what these patients get.
And also.
Can you say here, I.
Just lost George for an audio.
I was just going to ask. Me to. OK,
I can pick up a bit from
there.
There's been a kind of a problem
with osteopathic theory
over the years, which George is
hinting at around the reductionistic bio
biomechanical model.
And when it comes to complexity,
those sorts of traditional ways
of looking at people's chronic symptoms
leave something to be
well, they they're not
really, really things missing.
We we're realizing using
if we draw from other disciplines
we can see that
there's potentially a much better way
to describe
why people have these kind
of chronic type symptoms.
And I I came into this
a bit like Lucas with some
been quite surprised in practice
about how people react to treatment.
And I think we have a
it's almost a kind
of a tacit sort of thing
within the profession.
We we treat people
with emotional disturbance
but we don't actually confront it.
And so this conceptual framework
is actually starting
to redress the balance
which I think is really, really cool
and try to understand
why is it people react?
I think me this notion of prediction
areas is kind of an interesting one.
I, I came into it a long time ago
looking at it
from a psychodynamic point of view
and things could have reactions
but I think what we're moving
towards is trying to come up
with a bit more of a unified theory.
And that's why
I think the concepts of active
inference and activism
are actually starting to help.
But also at the
participatory sense, making
movement also adds a lot to
how we can start to understand it.
I know Luke has mentioned
we haven't talked about the therapeutic
relationship, but we are
there are other papers in the pipeline.
What about raising my voice
would so the summary for you, George
very interesting.
Yes, yes. Thank you, George.
No, no, no.
I think, Robert, these are brilliant
children summarizing everything.
So you all the challenges
and the reasons why we got interested
into exploring a different kind of way
of looking at things.
Francesco or Torsten,
would you like to add anything?
Otherwise, anyone in the live chat
is welcome to add a question
and I have some questions to
yes. Daniel so one other viewpoint
that I cannot at this point.
You stated from previous research
that actually we published looking at the
and using ephemera but also other
neuroscience, you know,
scientific tools like for example,
Time Will Comes.
We ended up understanding
or exploring the fact that actually
the brain is starting
to react to specific or general touch
in a kind of similar but different way.
So and these actually creates
a kind of a question,
a research question around.